[Music]
hasten is with us hasten
is in lexington south carolina hi hasten
how are you
hey thank y'all for having me sure how
can christina help
yeah so i kind of got a two-part
question what's my career and
and my debt situation uh right now i'm
24
um i'm a heavy equipment operator um
making probably about 2800 a month
and uh i've been with the company for
about nine months right now
and i can see myself moving up uh
like you know kind of climbing the
ladder uh
but my real goal is i want my own equip
after
after i mean it's my passion i love
wouldn't want to be doing anything else
and
um i just think that the real money is
on your own equipment you know uh and
and doing your own business whether it
be land clearing or
any kind of earthquake but and i'm sure
as you know
that equipment can get you know
expensive
and i was just seeking advice on what's
the smartest and fastest way i could get
to that point
um without you know going into that
obviously
yeah save like a crazy man
and pay cash for the oldest most beat up
worn out
piece of old stuff that'll push dirt
around that you can buy
use it on the weekends and the evenings
to earn more money
and then upgrade in traktor but pay cash
for it all the while
if you want to make sure this business
dream of yours turns into a nightmare
go 60 000 in debt to buy some stupid
bulldozer
that'll screw up your life don't
do that i do have a i do have a you know
i
in rece this is maybe last week i did
have a family member that
asked for me to sit down and talk to
them maybe
uh for an investment or investment in
because they know that's what i'm doing
and what it wanted to do and i just
didn't know how i felt about that
very sweet no okay okay
no you don't need an investor you need
money and because the investor is going
to be they own your business
yeah because they're the only ones
putting money in it all you did is 24
years old worth of sweat
yeah that's all you did yes and so
you're going to end up not owning
something
that way if somebody in the family has
some money and they want to give you
some money to get you started with a
good worn out used bulldozer and get you
to where you can go make some money with
that
and then work your way up with one piece
of equipment at a time paying cash at a
time
let me tell you man there's no situation
in the earth moving world
where brand new makes sense unless
you're a billionaire
yes sir because the stupid things go
down in value really
fast ask ask farmers who buy big
tractors
they drop in half in 24 months
it's like a stinking car that plows i
mean it's unbelievable how fast these
things go down in value
so these things are to make money with
not for you to pay caterpillar
you know you get to pay caterpillar
finance for the rest of your dadgum life
if you're getting these things
do not do that young man well the other
thing to keep in mind hasten is
is people are are hiring you to get the
job done not because your
tractor's shiny or because it's new or
because it's the certain model it just
needs to get the job done
does the dirt move you can get the job
done all that matters is did the dirt
move
it's all that matters nobody cared what
it looks like the only time that four
wheel drive
brand new 60 thousand dollar 80 000
silverados go through a mud pile on a
construction site is when an idiot's
driving it
that's the only time it happens and on a
commercial
this is the dave ramsey